uh you're gonna have to to wait and see
uh both what uh
sue says and also of course uh while the
net says but i'm here to talk about uh
the
the second anniversary of brexit is two
years ago since we got brexit done
you've been telling your mps privately
that you don't think you've done
anything wrong when it comes to parties
in downing street is that your position
that other people made mistakes but the
you didn't i'm here to talk about and
and
a lot of people our viewers want to know
the answer to that question do you think
that you the prime minister have done
anything wrong you're going to have to
wait and see the outcome of telling
people privately wait and see the
outcome of the of the investigations uh
but of course i i stick absolutely to
what i've said in the past but i'm here
to talk about uh you didn't do anything
wrong talk about the uh the free reports
that we're doing around the uk did they
get this on the record prime minister is
your position that you did nothing wrong
at all well i stick in complete you're
gonna have to we have to wait and see
what the investigations and we all you
know due respect uh but
what we're doing today is getting on
with uh
opening up free ports around the uk
eight free ports we're gonna do in
england uh one in northern ireland one
in wales one in scotland at least and
they have massive potential to unite and
level up